hello and this is the presentation about
anomalous breaks and outlier detection
in time series what I'm going to be
discussing is slightly different from
the from the abstract they submitted few
months ago actually wanted to react to
some of the - some of the definitions
some of the new technologies Stephen was
showing and so I assume actually it
seems that everyone who wanted to be
here is here so I'm going to actually go
to not going to expand too much on this
slide but most of the material here has
been already put into the quantile
regression live coding sessions so
defining anomalies it can be done in
several ways we can in I should have put
probably some graphics here but we have
like pointer normal is contextual
anomalies break points or change points
instructional breaks roughly speaking
the point of normal is any kind of
outliers like say let me see I should
have some data here let's say this hey
it's like a pointer normally we
obviously have some kind of groups and
is a contextual and in certain
situations like here we have like a
change point a break point so these are
too many people and too many algorithms
exist for doing this kind of
determination of anomalies or whatever
normally sees people use different
definitions people use different
algorithms it's a very fruitful subject
apparently if you have like a very
strong anomalies finder and this is
something say Steven mentioned in the in
the you know keynote yesterday you can
actually do quite a lot of anomaly
detection already with using some simple
techniques I'm going to show that very
bunch of anomaly detection packages this
is just - I have found these are and
it's like based on benchmarks this here
it's we already show
the part of the Numenta benchmark like
40 time series and these similar
benchmarks with a competition and for
forecasting competition with say hundred
100 thousand time series so it's I mean
well just forecasting but of course we
can actually ask ourselves can we
forecast anomalies so in this is
examples already showed as we can see we
have different type of for different
type of this is from the benchmark
Numenta benchmark and we have different
type of anomalies so vary this different
a different data set do we see anomalies
here we can claim yes basically this is
data from the variables and some
measurements done at a building of the
National Renewable Energy Laboratory and
I'm going to if I if I have time I'm
going to discuss some research based on
that so in general this is this is the
flavor here I want to to kind of do for
this talk in general with North America
but in general machine learning data
science we're trying to to to make
enthusiasm to be a good replacement of
expertise and in order to do that we're
certain to link and methodologies would
have to be provided I'm going to
actually mention couple of things I
think it's very fruitful to do when we
do this kind of research for normal
detections I'm writing a book on okay if
I do the satire the satire part of the
previous talk I'm also having an
upcoming book called how to be a data
scientist in pasta and the importance of
the data scientist in posters is
tremendous because I want to speed up
the next artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence winter to come
faster so I want to kind of remove as
many data scientists as possible and
then you know produce more interesting
research in
so how I'm going to be doing this
actually yeah that's interesting but let
me show you how so basically this here
it's very similar to the Wolfram Alpha
notebooks notebook edition and so this
here it's a series of commands but have
been natural language commands but have
been interpreted in order to make this
to make this evaluate find these
outliers and here I know like again with
some natural language commands you can
see this is the code being generated
under the hood with with this commands
and then if I copy and paste this code
this what is basically happened I can
you know I can produce this this plot so
how is this similar to what we have seen
before well the code generation part
with natural commands we cannot be
actually what-what precise when we are
specifying parameters of different
algorithms so this here it's not an end
user and user command sequence this is
more for data scientists or data
scientist imposters I generate the code
and from the generated code we do some
further manipulations and we do produce
some other stuff so this here you can
see why it's very similar I mean I'm
going to explain some of the outliers we
are we're going to detect so before
doing that I need to return to to my to
this slide here in which I want to say
but I do have two or three or five or
whatever but only three edges in this
presentation one-dimensional outliers
and this out one-dimensional outliers
I'm going to be using them for doing
different related thanks series finding
anomalies and outliers so you see that
this is the compel the S Plus and the
quarter quarter identifier the humble
one is much more permissive you can see
the outliers detected by example in the
and a little bit more conservative the s
plus one is the most conservative so
back to this example here so the the
thing is what very simply if I put some
regression quantile from my time series
I can reduce the identification this is
in blue I'm not sure how well we see it
but I can reduce the identification of
the time series outliers into this one
dimensional one dimensional type of one
dimensional problem and basically pick
the outliers which say above or below a
certain threshold actually what I'm
doing here here I'm actually using the S
Plus quartile identifier basically it's
picking the outliers in this in these
errors and so here we actually we can
plot them and see how well you know this
maps obviously another approach here
instead of using what outlier identifier
I can actually specify a threshold
basically I'm saying anything which is
above above this line parallel to the
axis 50 is an outlier and again you know
I'm going to be producing this alright
so great but what I mean how how good is
this and you can always come up with
some method like this in so obviously we
need to figure out how to measure
success and this is some of the bad news
in this field there is no nobody has a
great on on a consistent metric and so
again one of the things to if you do if
you want to do data science of beyond
imposter data scientist imposter you
need to figure out the measure of
success fairly quickly you need to
measure often and so this is a very
important important thing to figure out
before going further especially when we
are developing machine learning
algorithms will not just say you know
doing data studies here in this
presentation going to use receive
operating characteristics and
modifications of ads and somewhat
[ __ ] metrics so I think if you if you
are if you want to practice data sound
successfully I advise people to acquire
software software engineering skills and
software engineering skills means
software architecture which is a
lifetime quest and it's kind of hard to
teach not even say some book about
imposters or whatever but doing unit
tests and doing figuring out how to do
different different different
scaffolding datasets in order to test
the parameters the boundaries of your
algorithms this is extremely important
so this is for happening here right now
I have these few algorithms here which
basically take a normal time series and
not normal but sometimes series and they
produce they produce certain outlets and
I have specified how many outlets I want
and with what factor into etc so
similarly I can produce from this time
series I can just pull out some
fragments like below and above and
produce this type of time series so I'm
going to be using this for tests so this
is where you know we're discussing the
testing so here this is just my original
data and kind of showing and again
apologize this should be thank you
alright so so with this I have done some
of this you know finding anomalies by
residuals and I'm using the S Plus
portal identify earlier we saw that
using with natural language commands
this here it's just the monadic pipeline
so this so here I have found some
outliers then I actually have different
parameters with which I can do this what
we see here right I mean I can use a
different identifier I can use relative
errors or absolute errors I can change
the fire shots so I have made this list
of parameters here you can see you know
like different thresholds different
identifiers and so forth and after that
I'm actually trying to to figure out
here
do they you know what is the some simple
metric based on intersection which one
is say the best what is producing good
result instead of using intersections
it's much better to use receiver
operating characteristic see I'm using a
package for for calculating receiver
paretic characteristic functions and
here I'm comparing the standard true
positive rate and false positive rate a
very often people would actually say we
want to use the predictive positive
predictive value and so this is what
this plot is here and I cannot find the
reference but in a in a presentation or
an article I have seen some people using
weighted weighted version of the of the
of the recall the true positive rate and
the predictive positive predictive value
and so actually this should be life I
think yeah so basically here you know
obviously we don't need to use just one
3/5 or 1/5 or whatever I mean we can see
how this I don't see radical change
although via some kind of changes if I
increase this argument this wait some of
this algorithm start to look better all
less favorable so using so why I'm doing
this measuring the success in the
previous example here right measuring
the success of finding these outliers I
mean this is the reason I do actually
want to find out the others algorithms
working first and second switch of set
of parameters is better and then if I
have certain benchmark with certain type
of time series I actually want to train
say my models the parameters to be
selected against web page benchmark so
here before talking about the components
we need to talk about structural breaks
so basically I have this time series I
want to identify this this components
here you know in different colors and
the question is how successful I can
identify the components alternatively
you can say what I need to identify
these points here these are the change
points or the break points but well you
know I'm going to be identifying the
compar
as a whole and I'll explain why in order
to do that I need to first talk to you
about structural brakes structural
brakes we are not outliers here is a
here is an example you see actually
there's a line here it's a blue line so
if I take this one so so structural
brakes the points themselves were not
outliers but if they're splitting point
which splits the data set in two in two
parts which have very different modeling
modeling parameters in this particular
case I'm using linear regression you can
see the fidgets lines very different so
so I have this I'm I kept this algorithm
here for using structural brakes let me
see can I do something else here so
basically the Cho test statistic which
is testing for the how different the
models are is being systematically
applied then using some of the quantile
regression algorithms I have I identify
this local Peaks so basically what's
happening here it's this from the gray
points apologize there's a blue line
here from the gray points which are the
Cho test statistic this blue line is the
quantile regression is made from
quantile regression and in what what
blue line I can because Mathematica is a
symbolic system you know actually can do
differentiation I can find a local
extrema local Maxima and use those local
Maxima to actually find these fuzzy
peaks here and then use these fuzzy
Peaks to produce this you know these
candidates for structural breaks yeah
yeah this is what you are talking from
the perspective of someone observing the
time series scratching their head
pointing her finger yes
also recognizing cats is an easy problem
but we still do machine learning
algorithms for recognizing cats and dogs
so this is what this is this here what
we are doing is actually to automate
this recognition process and run it
against multiple multiple series which
also in some benchmarks and Exeter I can
expand on this I'm having a very short
time to finish this here so here you can
see with this basically with the
structural breaks I find very good
candidates for the change points and
here I have found this is the this is
the outcome of what I got from from this
from the components and now the question
is how good is this you know how good is
this well instead of using receive
operating characteristics using
intersections and you can see I expect
you know this actually here if I do some
statistics on the fraction of the of the
test data and in the components which
have found what exactly you know what
are the fractions I do that to get very
good results here I will protune istic
we use quantile regression to show to
show a different way of identifying the
components in the time series alright so
actually I do hear from quite a lot of
other things to discuss but using the
natural language I'm going to just come
this is the details this is the harder
the part of the talk that detailed
descriptions I finished with that one
thing or two or three things I I don't
see people doing is using natural
language techniques for for representing
time series here an example about that
you can see this in more details in the
live coding sessions
I'm not going to expand on this one of
the reasons though but I'm going to use
the opportunity here to explain
something else here you see I'm actually
seeing seeing the signal as a total
thing
I'm not actually predicting something as
a stream to be upcoming and so so this
is one of the things you know this
allows me to do this kind of this kind
of analysis Gela is what quantile
regression is very robust you see this
fitted regression quantiles here
quantile regression does not get best
easily by outliers if we did the
previous things that previous algorithms
I shot if I use linear regression or
something kills the outliers which have
best the model but front our regression
you know using quantiles they are more
robust estimator yeah I think is what I
can you see the signal here it's
heteroskedastic does this means what the
variance does not does not depend
depends on time if I go back to to one
of the original slides here which I
skipped is what I actually it's here
using the within quantile regression I
can very very easily find anomalous
points which are anomalous because of
the variance the points which are found
here where because the variance is much
lower than the others and here the
variance is much larger than the others
so this is again this is a fairly unique
unique ability given by quantile
regression people for whatever reasons
don't use it as often as we should
so anyway with the using using the
symbolic representation of the time
series we can do some interesting
Canales ease like say the mosaic plots
you can look at conditional
probabilities we can apply this here
this prefix tree you see here it's very
similar to what you see when Google
completes your phrases or checks your
spelling
so they mention reduction actually let's
go to this example I'm going to do it
all right so
witnessing so imagine you have four time
sitters like this
and I actually you know my the way I
generated this time series is through
this mandalas you know or whatever you
imagine what this mandalas we have been
sterilized they have been sent through
some channel and I'm getting this and
I'm getting this time series I'm having
outliers and now what I was seeing here
is with the dementia dementia reduction
first we have found the individual
components constituents of the of the
time series and this is just some kind
of fancy interpretation what else is
what we actually can approximate you
know Ixia have picked some kind of image
here and I can approximate it with this
dimension reduction by definition using
the measure reduction in reconstructing
the original entities we are doing it's
a generating procedure so some outliers
are going to be removed so a very
important perspective is using from my
perspective it's using operations
research and how how we use data
analysis in general the data science
machine learning to solve operations
research problems you see here this is
the the NREL data the national
environmental renewable Russia yeah
the Renewable Energy Laboratory the
original signals in red the simulated
signals in in blue the thing is what if
I combine some of the combined values
between the blue signals they might be
legal you can see just like say with
temperature and pressure you know I
might simulate the pressure and the
temperature separately but this doesn't
mean that in conjunction I produce good
results this is exactly what is
happening here I'm illustrating this by
using the I think you okay well I can
learn the distribution but I can also do
this waveform we find the normal lists
so basically here I have found some
anomalies in my simulations and these
are points which I'm going to say remove
and then if I remove a remove the points
I can you know have more faithful
simulation of the whole process so I'm
taking some deterministic variable say
temperature occupancy trying to predict
electricity consumption
I'm simulating each of this the
you know this regressive variables
separately the combination of these
variables it's not necessarily something
what I have seen in the data so so I
have made also some other normally
identifiers and this you know using
using recommender systems or using this
geometric nearest neighbors which are
shown here they have different
performance when find anomalies they're
also faster you know this is one the
last thing I'm going to show and I don't
have time to discuss it but we have
discussed anomalies in in single time
series but obviously we should be
interested you know normal is globally
into is a given time series anomalous by
itself if you look a big collection of
time series I do have a search engine
four times for time series and here you
can see how the search engine I have
basically drawn some profile and I have
found the most the most appropriate to
the closest time 0 speed and so other
similarly I can find this with the
nearest using nearest neighbors figure
out which of the signals have the least
amount of nearest neighbors where
references here at the end of the the
presentations references throughout you
know yeah thank you for your attention
you